the first Republican presidential
candidates debate is tomorrow night and
of course everybody is obsessed with
Donald Trump's appearance in the debate
I don't think people even know who else
is debating what's the point
it's like Trump and some other guys and
anyway the other guys the other
Republican candidates are all trying to
figure out how to handle Trump during
the debate they don't know how they're
going to handle them well we found out
that some of the candidates are
preparing by using a high-tech device
that actually employs sound bites from
Donald Trump these are very expensive
sophisticated machines the candidates
are using them to prepare we managed to
get our hands the trunk debate bot and
casino 5,000 won
[Applause]
very sophisticated machine thanks for
joining us for this practice debate mr.
Trump do you have an opening statement
our country is in very bad shape alright
okay very good very realistic all right
what is your number one qualification to
be president I was inducted into the WWE
Hall of Fame it's actually a great honor
okay cool
what is your advantage over Hillary
Clinton she's disgusting both inside and
out she talks like a truck driver what's
your position on the high stakes nuclear
deal with Iran believe me I understand
stakes it's my favorite food I'm sorry
excuse me
Trump steaks are by far the best tasting
most flavorful beef you've ever had no
no I'm not say about Trump steaks I'm
asking about Iran when it comes to great
steaks I've just raised the stage all
right is that stop telling me about
Trump steaks if I would Tom Brady I'd
sue the hell out of the NFL I'm sorry
can we just stick to one topic the
Academy Awards last night we're
absolutely terrible I never liked
computer-enhanced music there's nothing
better than properly done waffles and
syrup all over okay let's wrap this up
your final your final pitch the American
people mr. Trump steaks are the world's
greatest
[Music]
beats up today for a casino 5000 won
everybody thank you
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography